optimal room at this altitude like a non
flat out for a while before my hands
start shaking good oils we perfectly
know it is the cybernetic organism
living tissue over medical facility this
episode is brought to you by wealthfront
wealthfront is the future of financial
advice they've become incredibly popular
among my friends in Silicon Valley and
across the country because they provide
the same high end financial advice that
the best private wealth managers
delivered to the ultra wealthy but for
any account size and at a fraction of
the cost
for instance they monitor your portfolio
every day across more than a dozen asset
classes to look for opportunities to
rebalance or harvest tax losses now
would you do the same are you doing the
same probably not and the powers from
the software wealthfront now manages
more than four billion dollars in assets
which is up from around 2.5 billion when
they started advertising on this podcast
they're growing incredibly quickly
unlike old-fashioned Private Wealth
matters wealthfront
is powered by innovative technology
making it the most tax efficient
low-cost hassle-free way to invest they
don't a bloated sales teams or retail
locations so they can deliver all of
this sophisticated financial advice and
these services at a fraction of the cost
of a traditional financial advisor so
the very least go-to wealthfront com
forward slash Tim and take their free
risk assessment survey it only takes a
couple of minutes and wealthfront will
recommend a personalized portfolio of
investments in other words they'll tell
you exactly where they would put your
money so even if you don't use their
service you have a huge leg up and you
have additional information for making
good decisions they use investment
theory to automate good financial
behavior and decisions that people
typically don't make but should so go to
well front comm forward slash Tim to get
your first 15k managed for free or just
to get more details check it out well
front comm forward slash tip
this episode is brought to you by
99designs I've used 99designs for years
for all sorts of graphic design needs
whether you need a logo website cover
anything else 99designs was created to
make great designs accessible to
everyone to make the process of getting
designs much much easier so when I first
started out for instance testing
prototype covers and getting prototype
covers for our body
I want to contest route that is one
option this is a great solution if
you're looking for fast affordable
design work and the ability to choose
from dozens of options risk-free let's
say you need something late-night quick
turnaround well people in other times
other countries can also help you solve
that problem since then I've worked with
99 designs on a separate path or a
different option and that is the
one-to-one project service so in a
number of cases and I'll give you one
example when I wanted to create the
cover for my audio book The Tao of
Seneca this was a very important project
to me I decided to use their one-to-one
project service and with this service
you can invite a specific designer to
your project agree on a price and then
work together until you're satisfied and
they allow you to iterate and provide
feedback and all this stuff and I
haven't shared it yet but we also got
something credibly good really some of
the best illustrations I've ever seen
from using this one-to-one project
service with a handful of different
designers and illustrators it blew my
mind 99 designs makes this all very easy
and efficient so you can check out the
Tao of Seneca design and other work that
I and your fellow listeners for that
matter have done on 99 designs at 99
designs com forward slash Tim again
that's 99 designs dot-com forward slash
Tim
hello boys and girls this is Tim Ferriss
and welcome to another episode of the
Tim Ferriss show that is Molly chewing a
bully stick otherwise known as bull
fizzle in the background but you're not
here for that you were here for what we
do every episode that is deconstruct
world-class performers whether they are
from the worlds of business sports
entertainment chess or otherwise to
tease out the habits routines
philosophies beliefs etc that you can
apply to your own life and this time
around we have someone by popular
request who is perhaps all of those
categories wrapped into one
Adam Robinson Adam first appeared on
this podcast in the becoming the best
version of you episode which was number
210 so episode number 210 alongside Josh
Waitzkin who is best known for chest
jujitsu investing Andhra meet Sethi best
known for personal finance and
entrepreneurship so we had this
roundtable how'd you end your year all
sorts of great stuff came up so I
encourage you to listen to that as well
but this is a dedicated episode full of
Adam's stories and life lessons he came
out to San Francisco to spend time with
me I wanted to learn from him and that
is how it came to be Adam
Robinson has made a lifelong study of
outflanking and outsmarting the
competition he is a rated chess master
who has awarded a lifestyle by the
United States Chess Federation and as a
teenager he was personally mentored by
Bobby Fischer in the 18 months leading
up to his winning the World Championship
Bobby Fischer is considered by many to
be the best chess player who has ever
lived then in his first career Adam
developed a revolutionary approach to
taking standardized tests as one of the
two original cofounders of the Princeton
Review his paradigm breaking or as they
say in publishing category killing test
prep book the SAT subtitle cracking the
system is the only test prep book ever
do have become a near accounts
bestseller then after selling his
interest in the Princeton Review Adam
turned his attention in the early 90s to
the then emerging field of artificial
intelligence developing a program they
could analyze text and provide
human-like commentary he is a
jack-of-all-trades master of many he was
later invited to join a well-known quant
fund we could get into that another time
but well-known quant funds to develop
statistical trading models and since
he's established himself as an
independent global macro advisor to the
chief investment officer's of a select
group of the world's most successful
hedge funds and family offices so in
other words he is brought in to give
advice to billionaires mega billionaires
and beyond in his spare time for
instance he's also become pen pals with
Warren Buffett and we dig into Lots that
he's learned from Warren this is a
wide-ranging conversation with a lot of
takeaways I hope you enjoyed listening
to it as much as I enjoyed recording it
so without further adieu please enjoy my
conversation with Adam Robinson Adam
good sir welcome back to the show thanks
for having me Tim and we are sitting
here in Casa Farris on this comfortable
couch and viewing distance of my lovely
dog Molly and we could start just about
anywhere we have a thousand topics we
could explore and I thought we'd start
with an anecdote that made an impression
on me and I'd like to explore a little
bit could you talk about Warren Buffett
and his day planner please ha so we were
having dinner 10 of us with with Warren
and he held up with with great dramatic
effect his day planner for the year and
he said time is the most precious thing
I have he said I'm going to show you how
precious it is I'm going to show you my
day planner and eat so it's a little two
inch by three inch little booklet that
you get at any stationery store for the
year and he held it up for all of us and
he risked through it and every page was
empty and that was his day planner for
the year so so it's it's really
important to to Warren that his time is
his most valuable asset and what does he
do with all that empty space he reads
all day every day all day every day
reads thinks and hunts for his next
acquisition so that's that's what he
does with his time
he think of himself as an investor or an
acquirer of businesses at this point in
time how do you think he thinks to
themselves hey you know everyone calls
him the world's greatest investor and he
certainly the world's greatest something
but I think his is actually the world's
greatest builder of businesses and
acquire of businesses and so that's what
he does he acquires a business and tends
to hold it forever let's talk about
buglet investing but take a slightly
different tack we were chatting over
Thai food a little bit about a book
called and I'm like a title slightly
wrong but I believe it is you can be a
stock market genius it's something along
those lines
by Joel Greenblatt absolutely and that
that book cut in made an impression on
me and had an impact on me when I was
pretty young I think I was a little too
young for it when I was around 16 or 17
and directly preceded my first stock
purchase ever which was Pixar and when I
when I met Joel many many many years
later this is probably just a few years
ago he said that in some respects people
should read his books in the reverse
order of their publication because the
stock market genius book really covers a
lot of what some people might consider a
vent based investment or or training and
I was wondering if you had any thoughts
you brought up but I said hey let's
let's talk about it in the conversation
when were recording
you mentioned yes you were familiar with
with Joel and then also you brought up
Lynch Aaron Peter Lynch and so I'd love
to just hear you expand on what you're
going to say but I cut you off during
dinner because I want to save it for
this right so so Peter Lynch one up on
Wall Street and and and Joel Greenblatt
both brilliant investors both investing
geniuses and and my only concern about
about empowering individual investors is
that when you invest as an individual
you are entering the the fiercest
gladiatorial arena ever invented
the you're competing with highly
incentivized participants around the
world who are out for your lunch and
going to eat it if you're if if you
don't have an edge so I just want to be
sure that individual investors when they
choose to do that realize that it's
again a gladiatorial pit and and you
need an edge when you invest so what is
your take on then say a Lynch
or a green blot and in that capacity and
I don't know if it was reading blot who
could have been elsewhere when there's a
discussion about the edges the types of
edges you could have and one would be
informational advantage one could be a
analytical advantage another could be
say perhaps a behavioral advantage and
reading a lot about Buffett it seems
like at least one of his advantages
behavior these very unemotionally it
seems like affected by market movements
absolutely and can divorce himself
emotionally from these temporary ups and
downs but do you have any particular
observations related to Peter or Joel as
relates to advantages edges or otherwise
you know it's so funny and before we go
any further you know I because we this
is so much more intimate than a
conversation than we had at the 92nd
Street Y in front of a thousand people
and this is almost like parkour jumping
but a conversational version of that
where you leap from topic to topic not
knowing where you're going so the edge
Warren Buffett one of my favorite quotes
of Warren Buffett is if you're in a
poker game for 30 minutes and you don't
know who the Patsy is you're the Patsy
and so so you need an edge but you need
to know that you have an edge over the
market and in terms of information since
the 2000 the SEC
published Regulation FD fair disclosure
so in a sense everyone has access to the
same information at the same time so
information edges are very very
difficult especially with modern
technology and and other resources so
information edges are tough behavioral
edges are really important and you said
Buffett is completely unemotional so yes
when everyone is panicking is when he
gets greedy
in fact Buffett said Buffett articulated
in one sentence the the secret to
investing and and that's he said that we
meaning he and Charlie Munger are
fearful when others are greedy and we
are greedy only when others are fearful
and so the secret to investing in public
securities is knowing when to be afraid
and knowing when to be greedy to what
I'd like to do in this in this American
Ninja Warrior course of conversational
Park or maybe maybe take a step back
really far back and discuss a few of the
experiences your childhood because I was
not aware that you'd spent was it two
years two and a half years and half
years yeah in the hospital when you're
when you're a kid can you describe why
that was the case what happened sure
sure well it was a Blithedale Children's
Hospital which was started in in Wow
I think in the 40s by Eleanor Roosevelt
and it was for children with long-term
congenital illnesses and I had a bone
disease and back then the only way to
cure it was to put you in a bed and wait
for the disease to kind of run its
course and so know if you remember
Forrest Gump
at the beginning he had those leg braces
so between the ages of four and six and
a half I was wearing those leg braces in
a bed in the Children's Hospital yeah so
what was what was your childhood like ah
when where'd you grow up so I grew up I
was born in New York and and then was
put in the hospital and then when I got
out we moved to to Chicago to Evanston
Illinois
I was sure northwestern is so if you've
seen in the movies like Ferris Bueller's
Day Off or home Alone's which were all
filmed and within a mile where I grew up
so that was that was the where what
would you and if you were to paint
because we talked a little bit about in
the last episode Princeton Review yeah
we talked about that chapter of your
life in part but what were some of the
formative influences in your life up to
say end of high school influences or
events anything like that you know being
in the hospital for two and a half years
as you're growing up you you get
divorced from your body in a hospital
bed and and you you get divorced from
the world the world is something out
there that you can't touch and you can't
participate in and you but you observe
it and you think about it and I guess
one of the formative influences was was
meeting Bobby Fischer has my hero how
did you meet Bobby Fischer and for those
people who don't know who Bobby Fischer
is how would you encapsulate and Fischer
is said by some to be the greatest chess
player of all time and I met him right
before he won the World Championship and
knew him right through the World
Championship and then sadly afterwards
she began to lose his mind to to
paranoia and died in 2007 sad but I knew
him at the height of his powers right
before he won the World Championship and
it's funny how I met him he freshman
year when I was in high school somebody
beat me in a game of chess in homeroom
beat me in like five moves like I knew
how the pieces moved but that was the
extent of my knowledge and this so
frustrated me I thought okay I'm going
to challenge him to a game the next day
and he beat me again in fact he beat me
every day that week so I resolved that I
would study this game and just in order
to
beat this kid by the end of the year
that was my sole goal and because I was
really into swimming at the time you
know swimming four or five hours a day
you know six seven days a week and chess
was really much a sideline for me but I
got into the game and and I decided to
go to the library actually a book store
and get a chest book and the only book
they had was a book called my 60
memorable games by Bobby Fisher and at
the time this was four years before he
would win the World Championship
so I played over these games every night
these 60 games and I realized the wait a
second he played hundreds of games so I
went to the library this is pre-internet
for for those of you Millennials who
don't know what a library is and and I I
got to went it was the slow version of
the Internet it has the slow version of
the Internet yes when you actually had
to look up things yourself and I went
through 20 years of back issues of chess
magazines laborious ly every chess
magazine that I could find in the world
and went through page by page and I
found a Fischer game I would write it
down so I compiled my own notebook of
about 700 of his games that he had
played and I played over these games for
two three years and I knew them by heart
when you say played over yes does that
mean you would set up a board or did you
do this in your head and you would go
move by move through both players
exactly decisions exactly you gotta get
on a board on a board yes it some people
could do it in their heads I mean like
Magnus Carlsen world champ or Josh
Waitzkin our buddy uh they can do it in
their head I had to use a board and so
so I remember it was my I was 16 years
old with my mother on Easter Sunday and
visiting her in New York and we were
walking up 6th Avenue toward Central
Park beautiful April day and across the
street across 6th Avenue right in front
of Macy's I saw Bobby Fischer so imagine
this was my hero right and again this
was a year and a half before he would
win the World Championship and
again for those of you don't know that
it would be like spotting Bigfoot or I
mean he was or JD Salinger baggage right
right back in the day and so I said mama
I know I I said I would spend today with
you but that's that's Bobby Fischer over
the I'll see you later
so I cut across traffic I ran up to him
and I I said that mr. Fischer mr.
Fischer in 1962 when you were playing
reshef ski in the US Championship you
know because I had years of questions
for him and I knew all his games by
heart and he just and he's by the way he
was a notorious recluse he had maybe two
friends in the entire world and and he
just looked at me kind of amused because
I knew his game so well and he said why
don't know we're going to I'm going to
lunch want to join me and I said sure of
course like right and that was the
beginning of a friendship that lasted
two and a half years it actually
stretched beyond that but after World
Championship but I I fell out of touch
with him for about a dozen years because
he fell off the map for a dozen years so
you met him you held me at the time he
said 16 he was 28 16 yeah what was that
first was that first lunch like if I
mean fantastic I mean imagine you you're
meeting your hero that no one gets to
talk to and here he is inviting you to
lunch I mean fantastic and I wish I
realized at the time how how lucky I was
and but I wasn't thinking about that I
was only thinking about him and and his
cash games and and I remember talking
with him and people don't know I mean
they take a of chess players as you know
intellectual nerds and very not athletic
but he was built like an Olympic athlete
he was 6-3 an eighth literally two meals
over lunch like two whole 9-volt aeneas
meals whoo simultaneous meals he just
demolished again and when I say an
Olympic athlete I don't mean like a
power lifter he was like a like an
American football player
I just put very lean and
incredible energy when we walk down the
street again
I'm 5/8 he's 6 4 he towered over me and
walked with his huge strides I mean I'm
incredible power you know and the
amazing thing about Fisher was that and
I don't think this has ever been done in
the history before he was entirely
self-taught he learned the game at the
age of 6 and then decided to take on the
Russians for whom chess was their
national sport it was proof of their
superiority trying to hide the Cold War
and single-handedly beat them at their
own game he had no coaches no nothing
and did it all on his own and remarkable
remarkable guy we are we we I remember
debating Motown songs with him we were
at a diner and we had we had dollars
between us but we had no coins they just
had these little jukeboxes at each
dining table you put in a quarter you
have three songs we had a quarter
between us and so we were debating which
three songs we we were going to choose
he loved Motown and so did I so I came
up with songs we picked but I remember
doing that with him how did that first
lunch turn into an ongoing relationship
and maybe a better question would be to
what happened at in the last half or
quarter of that meal that led to a
second meeting you can tackle it either
way I'm just so curious because people
have these opportunities these golden
opportunities right and then they're not
able to capitalize on them or it's a
flash in the pan they have a great
single story but that turned into an
ongoing relationship why right because I
was totally focused on him and I it
never occurred to me when I first
approached him that he would say get
lost kid I just had questions and and he
was my hero and it was entirely innocent
and and and I'd done my homework
I knew his game is better than he did so
I remember talking about games and we
played hundreds of games of speed chess
and to mention playing pick-up
basketball and you're a very good
basketball player but you're playing
with you know Kobe Bryant or or or curry
right I mean what one of the grades and
I remember I would play his moves
against him because I knew all of his
games by heart and then he would correct
me like he would I'd say oh I don't
understand why you played that because
you said black is better in your book
and he said I did I said yeah you did
and I he said oh I was wrong
White's better and the freshman um and
so it was I think it was just because I
knew his game so well I done my homework
and and I think the lesson for for
everyone is is if you've done your
homework to to to be focused on the
other person and not your fears and
reservations and and and yeah so the in
terms of continuing the relationship
focused on them in the sense of being
curious about them as opposed to
worrying what they're thinking about you
exactly totally focused on them and is
interesting because he would then
reflect it back on me so the next year
when he was preparing for the Spassky
match I'm I got to spend two weeks with
him spassky's World Championship right
for the World Championship right now you
think if there was any time that he
wanted to be alone it was like preparing
for the oil change but I he invited me
to spend two weeks with him that at
Grossinger's
and Grossinger's at the time was a
resort in the Catskills and Muhammad Ali
used to Train there and so they invited
Fischer to train for the Spassky match
and I got to spend a week with him two
weeks with him at there all alone and
watched him prepare for the Spassky
match which was really fast thing so we
play over game studying and then he
would turn to me and say well what would
you do here and ice would you say play
over games and I apologized yeah I
wouldn't consider myself a chess player
by sure that means that he's sitting in
front of a board by himself hmm
he's hitting over a board by himself
well with me
I'm putting neck
to him a rather across the table from
him and he's got a full chessboard and a
book of spassky's games it was a red
book like 600 games and just as I did
with Fischer's games he had a little red
book of spassky's games and he just
played over these over and over it was
really fascinating and I don't think
people realized Fischer conducted the
longest con in sports history a long con
and and if you're not sure what a long
con is I mean I know you know Tim but
but for your listeners a long con is is
it is a is when a confidence man sets
you up and the payoff is years away not
like later that day and so Fischer when
he was growing up played always pawn to
King four as his first move and and and
had a very limited opening repertoire in
terms of in football terms he had a very
limited playbook and he always played
the same opening moves and he defied the
Russians and defied the world to beat
him but essentially he's giving here's
my playbook that these are my opening
moves do your best and so from the age
of mmm 12 till the age of 29 when he's
right so this is 17 years he played
exactly the same opening moves and what
was curious for me was that when I was
with him about a month before the Tsar
two months before the match began I
noticed he was playing studying games
outside his opening repertoire and I
asked him I said Bobby what are you like
why are sitting those games and he just
kind of smiled cryptically and I said I
don't know we'll see
and and sure enough against Spassky now
mind you the Spassky was supported by
the Russian chess machine right dozens
of the world's top players were all
Russian who were supplying Spassky with
analysis of all of Fischer's old games
but then he played an entirely new
opening
repertoire he set them up for 17 years
is that these are the moves I'm going to
play so imagine it'd be like a boxer
always batbot you know leading with his
right hand and then all of a sudden he's
leading with his left and they didn't
know what to do they were totally
flummoxed or Dread Pirate Roberts from
The Princess Bride
okay I'm not left-handed one of those
that is exactly right the Princess Bride
yes ayuh came we're talking about her
yesterday and what what are some of the
other things you observed about Fisher
or learned from Fisher does anything
come to mind
he was very childlike very simple in his
analysis of the games you know Oliver
Wendell Holmes one of my favorite quotes
is he said I wouldn't give anything for
the simplicity on this side of
complexity but I'd give my life for the
simplicity on the far side of complexity
and Fisher was the simplicity on the far
side of complexity it was the informed
simplicity not the uninformed yeah it's
like Picasso you know it's funny I
always dismiss Picasso as a painter not
that I'm an art expert but it's only
when you when you see his paintings as a
16 year old and he's painting like
Rembrandt so when he went over and as an
adult and started painting like a child
that was an informed simplicity it was a
choice
and Fisher was like that in what other
ways did the childlike nature manifest
itself its enthusiasm always he was
enthusiastic about everything in the way
that he explained things like I remember
once we were looking at a position on
the board and he had again he was 64 he
was enormous and he he he's trying to
teach me a lesson about the position of
chess pieces on the board and he held
his hand over a few pieces and he said
if if your pieces can move outside of
your hand they're too far apart they're
not well coordinated like it was a
physical an intuitive mmm encapsulation
of a very profound
principle that to be illustrated again
physically with his hand your pieces
move outside your hand the too far apart
they can't coordinate you're like do you
mean your size pancake or my little my
little is exactly the actors you can
practically is half the board yeah so so
so that's how genius manifests itself as
a childlike simplicity what are other if
there are other essences of genius in
your mind because you you and we talked
about this a bit in the first episode we
I'm sure we'll touch on this in a few
different ways in this conversation but
you have been successful in many
different worlds and you've met many
people who are geniuses in different
domains so that's aside from this
childlike simplicity that is on the
other side of complexity what are other
essences of genius in your mind I think
the American psychologist Maslow said if
your only tool is a hammer you view
every problem as a nail and I would flip
that and say that if you're the geniuses
have very limited tool sets they have a
hammer and their genius is in looking
for nails because right that's their
genius right they have a very limited
skill set but they they master it and
apply it incredibly well you know I'm
reminded the of the movie Karate Kid
right or is wax on wax off
you know sand the floor right and then
you had that crane kick you move anyone
the California state championship on the
base of those three and I'm goofing here
on on on the Karate Kid but but I think
it illustrates a a profound point to to
master a few skills well and and then
look for domains when you
can apply those skills and stay out
everything else Warren Buffett does the
same thing with his embed I was going to
ask you and then then I want to come
back to you but in the case of say
Buffett
what are his wax on wax off crane etc
what is his one of his primary
superpowers and how much are they innate
versus developed or acquired maybe his
better way to put it right well you know
that one of the great partnerships of
all time was was Charlie Munger and and
and and Warren Buffett and and and and
the two of them spent all the time just
weeding and just looking and by the way
other great investors like fans all do
the same thing they spend all the time
on the prowl the prowl for ideas or
prowl for businesses are they reading
primarily filings are they reading it
far-ranging books on different subjects
on everything on everything you just
don't know where you're going to get
your next idea not so much filings I
mean they would look read those too of
course but read far and wide because you
just don't know where you're going to
get your next investment idea and I
think that's one of their superpowers
and and the other is a long-term focus
with the Buffett and Munger so when
everyone is panicking say and in in 2007
when the world seems to be imploding
very really looking for for values so
they invest for the long haul and they
don't get distracted by vicissitudes
economic or or otherwise you mentioned
so I'm going to go back to you in the
library
sure all right you're going through
hundreds of games from taking notes yeah
on the Bobby's orbit going through years
back issues magazines sure and taking
down all the Fischer games yeah I would
imagine Saul I did right so now I'm
imagining there were not many kids in
your class or your
school who did this so the question is
what do you think your core strengths
are and what are some of the core
strengths you've developed that you
didn't have at a young age right or
weaknesses that you have have overcome
well I always look for and we talked
about this in at the 92nd Street Y for
things that don't make sense I look for
patterns I look for for quirks even in
my own mind I remember let's see how old
I was nine years old and I was listening
to miss Callahan who is my teacher and I
was in love with her and she was using
she she she was talking about something
again I was just totally in love with
her and I don't forget what she was
talking about but she she spoken and I
realized she spoke the word of and I
realized oh I don't know how to spell
that word now what was fascinating is I
mean I had learned how to read when I
was five in the hospital but I was
stunned that I didn't know how to spell
a two letter word and so I spent the
rest of the day trying to spell the word
of and this is the way I did it my job
is nine years old I said okay I knew the
first letter was a vowel so on a sheet
of paper I wrote AEIOU and then I wrote
why because sometimes wives of all and
then I wrote all the consonants ABCD and
so on and I spent the rest of the day
going through every possible pattern
like a B and it's the app is that up
okay that's not and then AC and AD and I
went through every single permutation
trying to find the word of and I never
found it because the others is not a
it's not it's not phonetic stuff another
game that I use a tough language that
way yes I didn't realize that at the age
of nine but I think that was one of my
core strengths looking for patterns and
things that don't make sense and and
being amused by my own mind and failings
and but I
four seconds for sure why doesn't
everyone everyone why didn't you ask how
to spell it
as opposed to going through that
exercise because I I wanted to because
the real question was why I couldn't
spell it not not what is the answer what
is the answer and well it's such an
important thing you know thank you for
bringing that up because the questions
you asked about the world determine the
success you you you get in the world and
one of my favorite questions is Tony
Robbins what would you do if you knew
you couldn't sail and so the questions
we ask are key so I wasn't interested in
the answer how to spell the word of I
mean I I knew that was trivial I knew it
was a two letter word but what wasn't
trivial is that I couldn't spell it why
do you think that is because that that's
an odd that is it strikes me as very
unusual that you would have learned to
read but then for years three four years
later would have this word that sticks
out is something that you couldn't spell
away with just a one it was one second I
knew it the way you can forget
somebody's you know the name of an actor
in a movie or something I knew it was a
momentary glitch but I was I was
fascinated by it and looking back on it
I was
I'm fascinated at the age of nine I was
very systematic I had two columns and
spent the rest of the day ignoring miss
kau her hand and the rest of the class
since I spent most of my time
daydreaming anyway and she would just
let me trying to figure out how to spell
the word up very systematically and that
and I thought that was a good use of my
time
you mentioned questions and love to ask
you because I think they're related you
can you can place this at any time we're
going to jump around chronologically
since this is hardcore
that's parkour never know what what what
obstacles coming up next yeah and
decision making what is your
decision-making process for choosing
opportunities or your criteria or how do
you think about choosing opportunities
or more so than finding when you have a
number of different opportunities a
number
different paths you could go down what
is your decision-making process or your
selection process the problem is I'm so
intellectually curious that I really
have to be careful because it's going
down a rabbit hole I'm gonna have to
limit the things that I allow myself to
be interested in and I think I choose
the one that's the most fun and and and
I guess my life is like parkour right
just jumping in and and and and knowing
that you'll be resourceful and land on
your feet and then be able to jump from
there too so I look also for for areas
that we touched on this the ball
bearings principle right for
opportunities with things that people
haven't explored before and/or they've
explored to death and they they're no
longer interested and so I try to look
for things with with fresh eyes yeah and
for the ball bearing spokes we could go
into it but we we spent quite a bit of
time on in the first episode of Adam so
you guys can explore that there I'd like
to talk about post Fisher
where did you go to college I went to
Wharton undergrad and then I got a lot
of great Oxford and how did you choose
Oxford then we're going to talk about
apples oh yes yes apples granny smith
apples okay
I chose Oxford Mike I you know my father
died when I was 19 and I was pretty lost
and I could have finished Wharton in in
in two years two and a half years anyway
because it takes six or seven courses a
term and because I found everything
really interesting and you only required
to take four and take six or seven and
my father died and I didn't know what to
do and I I wanted to get away and
I don't speak any foreign language
fluently enough to to go to a country
other than like say England so I chose
Oxford and I thought law would be an
interesting way to beguile a couple of
years to three years so it was kind of a
default actually and and while I was
there I spent most of my time taking
dance classes in London
hip hop table tennis oh yeah in London
yeah yeah sorry I'd only I was the not
the most conscientious law student at
Oxford but but anyway so that's what I
did if you only asking we don't have to
get into if you don't want to but how
did you had to do that pence he took his
life and he suffered from depression as
I did and uh you know I remember the
last thing he said to me before before
he did so he said you know I'll always
remember that you did everything on your
own and I didn't realize that he was
using past tense then right he said I'll
always remember that you did everything
on your own this is Latin in two years
two hours later he was you know the
police called and said he was dead and I
am and he did me a disservice because
for and we'll get to this later in our
parkour excursions but you know for four
decades I I did do everything out of my
own and it's only this last year that I
realized the importance of the other
with a capital T capital o that magic is
is unleashed in the world only when
you're a circuit is is opened when
you're when you're connecting with
someone else and that and that's where
the magic and the miracles occur and I
wish I had known that earlier
why don't you think you explored that
earlier I wasn't aware of it you mean
the other yeah yeah the magic that
occurs um
because I was always in my own world
right I mean I was an introvert
in high school I didn't discover this
too later there were people that had
never seen me speak people were around
me every day for four years had never
seen me speak and and then and yet I was
so animated with Fisher right and
running up to him so I lived in my own
world and and I the world of ideas
so I mean I was aware of other people
and of course we all are but I was an
introvert to to an otherworldly extreme
and and then only this year have I
realized and been excited really excited
I'm by engaging other people and with it
you know and we should revisit those
three rules of success that we talked
about it at the 92nd Street Y because
they're all about other people we can
talk about them now if you'd like her we
can come back to it given preference no
no you're the conductor here yes you're
the ringmaster all right we're going to
come welcome back to that after the
tragedy with your father involving your
father you head to Oxford you're taking
dance lessons ostensibly you're there
for law yeah yeah this is this is a left
turn yet again but how do we talked
about this a bit last night and I just
remember saying what so how do how do
apples enter the scene oh yeah you mean
my my nutritional Odyssey yes your
nutritional Odyssey and why why did it
why does it become what it was yeah so
so I arrived at Oxford and I had prepaid
for room and board and you know it's a
cliche to say again this is back then
actually and the food you can get in
England now is fantastic but back then
when I was a student it was a cliche to
say English food was was awful but then
English institutional food was it was
inedible and I and I couldn't afford I
could only afford to eat one meal a day
and out I you know pay in a restaurant
and because I'd already
hate for room and board and I refused to
eat the food so I used to go to the the
only restaurant that I could afford in
Oxford was a vegetarian restaurant and I
started eating just vegetarian food and
I and I realized as the days went on
that that there were three food groups
there were foods that made me feel
really good foods that were neutral and
boots that made me feel bad and the the
foods that made me feel good the granny
smith apples carrots raisins
oh I remember with the Forth Worth
cabbage cabbage cabbage and the the
neutral foods were vegetables green
vegetables red vegetables but not white
like rice or corn anything any grains
were negatives
meat was a became a negative and dairy
products were negative and so my whole
life I'd been training for five hours a
day swimming sauce weightlifting and
then at Oxford I do nothing except deed
granny smith apples basically how did
the negative affect you oh oh if I had
oh I love for example milk with my
coffee and if I had so much as a
teaspoon of milk and my coffee I'd get a
sore throat I'd get instantly congested
I I'd get tired and so I just weeded all
those things out so that by the end of
the year I was basically a fruitarian I
think Stephen jobs for a while was a
fruitarian and and so was I and I was a
bore to be around because people would
say let's go out for lunch and I'd have
like a salad or or have to look out the
mr. ed special please yeah it's exactly
the mr. ed special and so I come back
and I had lost 20 pounds and to put that
in perspective for people I mean you are
not Bobby Fisher right so at the time
before you lost the 20 pounds what was
what was where were your dimensions like
I was 135 pretty solid muscle because
I've been an athlete my whole life right
and at five eight said if I may yeah
you lost 20 pounds yeah yeah and but I
wasn't aware that I was that skinny
because your body image shifts with it
but I just wasn't hungry like a meal for
the for the day might be a pound apples
or two pounds of apples maybe some
carrots really mr. ed right and then I
just wasn't hungry and some days I would
need it all and anyway so come back to
to New York where I was living at the
time my mother was living and I go to my
brother's health club because I decide I
should get back in shape I hadn't
trained for a year and imagine you Tim
Ferriss not training for a year right
and so I remember the first machine i
sat on was this Nautilus a shoulder
press and I I said it for five plates
like fifty pounds and because I didn't
want to overdo it and my arms shot up
they were weightless and then and then I
asked my brother who's standing next to
me I said Matthew just lowered a couple
plates and then make it 17 it also shot
up and I said okay Matthew lowered a
couple more because I need a little
weight so that's too light so he does so
and and then I I pressed like 20 times I
said yeah that's about right and he
comes around the front of the of the
machine he said okay I'm not going to do
anything I just wanted to come back
around to the the place the setting were
behind you right where I said it and
he'd set it on the very lowest setting
like the full stack like that football
players right and every machine was like
that I could max out on all the machines
easily with no effort so uh it's so odd
because I had you know lost all this
weight hadn't hadn't trained for for
over a year and even if that when I was
at its peak condition I wasn't able to
do that prior to the dietary Odyssey
that I went on and had to explain that
yourself well I I actually then started
doing research like I discovered for
example that primitive man ate only
fruit they've done they did molar
studies that of
found of skeletons and things and
primitive man that if you ate vegetables
there were fiber scratches on the on the
molars and there were none so they
concluded that primitive mended
basically eating mostly fruit and so I
don't know I think it was just you know
what now that I think about it Tim it's
exactly what you do you endless the
experiment to find the optimal
combination of whatever to max out your
performance on whatever dimension and
that's what I did unwittingly and you
know I weeded out the foods that made me
feel bad and focused increasingly on the
foods that made me feel good and that's
what I did so I was it I was a Tim
Ferriss acolyte there before you were
around have you and I'm guessing you've
probably not replicated the new me
the Granny Smith experiment I'm very
curious and I'm not recommending folks
by the whether you go out and do the the
Apple only diet but we were joking last
night about how there are at least two
foods that I've experienced during
certain training periods that seem to
have an odd performance-enhancing effect
one so this is a long story guys well
I'm not going to get into this too much
but for whatever reason tart apples yeah
and lentils for me also at which which
many people don't respond well to but
very very odd and well you know it's not
on and you know and again neither of is
advocating you know that you start
consuming granny smith apples
exclusively but certainly you should pay
attention to your body's responses to
any food and and again I I had a
taxonomy of three food groups those that
made me feel good
those that were neutral and those best
avoided and and and all of us should do
that not just with our foods with
everything in our lives right
optimize our functioning and that's what
you're all about it is in a lot of ways
now these days though you do consume
your coffee with milk sure
so then I think this is how I
okay powder Caleb you did you gradually
reintroduce these foods including
negatives that you wanted to include or
sure I mean the I was a bore to be with
because I people invite me out to a
Japanese restaurants and I'd say oh I
really can't eat anything on the menu
you have apple right apples and so so it
took me a couple of years actually to
get back to normal eating and so right
now I healthily but I eat some negatives
that you know I I try to limit dairy
products but but I love I love milk in
my coffee so what the hell yeah you know
I know it's not optimal for my body but
but I enjoy it was it it was the
Elizabeth Taylor I want to say said
something along the lines of the problem
with people who don't have vices is that
you can be pretty sure they've very
enjoying virtues they all need a few
vices here and there let's let's go back
to the three rules for success
can you I'll let you take it from here
the mic is yours
sure well you know and and just by way
of a background it began when you asked
me how you you mark the end of a year
and I said well I I reflect on the
lessons I learned the past year and I
make a conscious effort to apply them in
the coming new year because you asked me
this what a month ago right in Israel
right back in December and and so I
thought you ask what did I learn in 2016
and I said I learned three things and
and I I learned the importance of fun
enthusiasm and delight in everything you
do absolutely everything and first and
foremost fun enthusiasm and delight
we'll come back to that
the second is connecting with everyone
you encounter on however fleeting a
basis and you've been with me and you
see I do that
uber drivers maitre d's everybody you
name it I dry time I put that into
action you really connect with the
person happen in in however fleeting
that connection is but you make an
effort to make a connection and and the
third is to lean into each moment and
each encounter and everyone you meet
expecting magic or miracles and and
those are the three things I learned and
the interesting thing about all of them
is that none of them have anything to do
with me it's all about the other person
right
and when I say fun delight and
enthusiasm it's to create fun delight
and enthusiasm for the other person and
that that goes for if you're going to a
meeting and you want to you with a
venture capitalist because you're
looking for funding for your startup or
you're going on a date or you're you're
going on a job interview forget the fact
that it's an interview you're going to
delight the other person that's what
you're there for
first and foremost and to make
connection and if you do if that's your
focus as opposed to getting the job or
getting the funding then you get magic
and miracles but that should be your
primary focus and and what it does is it
it gives you infinite power because you
want nothing and you're offering
everything all I want and that's what I
in this moment now with you sitting is
sitting in front of you on your couch it
still is to connect with you and to
delight you
so what's I'm playing a game I can't
lose and I'm in total control and I
don't want anything and so that's the
such a revelation for me and I wish I
had known that earlier how did how did
that be curious to hear how that
revelation came about so you mentioned
depression earlier which I definitely
want to talk about and I've certainly
talked and written
about my own battles with extended
depression and some very severe episodes
over the years and you mentioned Tony
Robbins earlier so Tony Robbins I
remember underscored something for me
maybe a year and a half ago which was
effectively suffering as an excessive
focus on yourself
there you go yourself right that was a
lesson that I underlined and highlighted
and revisited many times since he
imparted that to me because it seemed
like the best medicine for fixing myself
was to stop focusing on myself in many
respects absolutely I and I Tony Robbins
one of the Great's right however with
respect to depression one of the
insidious things not insidious isn't the
right word one of the sinister things
about depression is that it it's a it
works by getting a vice grip on your
thinking so you're incapable of thinking
outside of yourself that and really the
worst aspect of depression between the
ages of Oh golly 14 and say 30 there
wasn't a day I
I didn't wrestle with the hamlet
question to be or not to be
and the worst thing about and some days
for example I remember a period for a
couple months I didn't leave my
apartment I the blinds drawn I would
order in from from a deli and the worst
aspect of depression is that you you
come to despise yourself and you you you
believe that only now in depression are
you thinking clearly yes and that before
you were delusional yes this man and you
hate yourself for it you you hate
yourself for being deluded and that
nobody understands now now I am thinking
clear
now nothing matters and and and that's
that's really the devil at work that's
why I say sinister because depression
traps your thinking and at hijacks your
thinking like a virus and and you
despise yourself you despise yourself
for being deluded previously and a lot
of people in their lives despising
themselves what took you out is that
pattern mentioned I'm blanking on the
exact ages because it's something like
14 to 30 years sure and then and then
episodically after that point I mean
between 14 and 30 was it was unrelenting
it was a siege of me against my my
depression and then it was episodic and
then I'm not sure it just I don't know
if it was biochemical but it just lifted
and if you let me ask me I sure when it
listed how old were you when I say
lifted it again it would it could come
back sure um but I haven't for example
now I haven't had an episode in
depression in probably mm a decade
that's a lot that's a long very long
stretch and I I think it's a biochemical
shift because depression also as you
know and the word depression reflects
not just a mental state but the physical
state your energy level is low and I
think you know and to go back to Tony
Robbins you know one of the great things
about Tony Robbins who's high energy and
you think about all like Richard Branson
and Elon Musk and you Tim high energy
and and and one way to to to escape from
slipping into depression is to be ever
vigilant about keeping your energy level
high and to notice the biochemical
markers
proceeded depression so you can head it
off at the pass before you you slip into
it because once you slip into it
I mean you yeah you know it's very
difficult you're essentially you're
going to go down that slope for a while
and then it's going to take you know
days or weeks or months to come out of
it what are sort of V it's not red flags
but orange flags for yourself the
biochemical markers that would tell you
check engine light okay something
something we're out in the wrong
direction right certain seasonal things
like in the winter and people suffer
from seasonal affective disorder it's I
think it's really just noticing your
energy levels day to day for me
personally that was the marker for me
and each individual will have markers
there will be if you suffer from
depression and by the way neither of us
is giving medical advice no of course
we're not eating or investment advice or
advice of any kind informational
purposes on informational purposes only
but but but all of us should become
aware of and again this is a first
principle first first principle or axiom
is is to is to be aware of what works
and what doesn't work and and keep
experimenting and and and doing more of
what works and less of what doesn't work
and and and eventually you you you
optimize and become a very high
functioning individual so I'm going to
come back to depression I'm gonna shift
gears a little bit I'm going to come
back to because in my interactions with
you I know your brain works very well in
this conversational format sure sure so
I'm going to allow the question on
depression which is going to be 10 years
ago when you seemed to click out of that
sure condition what things correlated
were there other things new people in
your life new behaviors dietary changes
whatever might be we don't have to hit
it right now but I'm going to let that
leave at it as the parentheses we'll
come back to it we'll come back to it I
know that that will be working on the
back burner in your head you're sure
things that work and to provide some
some context for folks so you were very
kind to come out and visit me in San
Francisco
and you brought a lot of ideas with you
and I remember this was after at the 92y
Josh agreed that you were one of the
best gift givers in the world yeah and
the gift said would take you some time
to prepare and then there were ideas for
me and you came out to share them and
we've been spending a lot of time
together
yeah you have also been writing a book
and I you've been taking a lot of baths
and we're asking do you always take
baths when you are working on some type
of creative product project me said well
you preserve the threebees of creativity
I said so I am thought so speaking of
things that that work can you describe
the three B's of creativity or this so
the three B's of creativity you know
creativity is getting in touch with your
unconscious and and you know you you you
consciously pose a question to your mind
and you allow your unconscious to to
percolate on it and and Josh are besties
it's written extensively about this and
and and and few people in the woods do
it better than he does but the three B's
are bed bath and bus and and bus is a
metaphor for traveling so when you want
to when you have a problem that you're
you you've your your conscious mind has
thoroughly exhausted then you give it
over to your unconscious and so you go
to sleep right that's bed for me which
could be a long overnight sleep or it
could be a nap right could be a nap you
want to get to the dream state bath
which you could do at any point also or
you switch location bosses again a
metaphor just for alliterative purposes
you switch your your location and and
and that allows your your unconscious
mind to to address the problem and that
again that's where the magic occurs your
unconscious mind we've in in
in Western civilization over the last
few thousand years we've we've deified
logic and rationality and the irrational
intuitive mind has gotten a you know
short the short end of the stick and and
we dismiss it but that's actually our
intuitive minds in our unconscious mind
I would say our primitive mind in that
sense is far more advanced and far more
powerful than then the advances we've
made in logic and and deductive thinking
which is in our unconscious Minds like a
supercomputer and compared to the
trivial apparatus of our logical mind
husband this is something I've been
thinking about a lot in the last three
years and some of it relates to
psychedelic research we'll call it but
that's there are two episodes on that
for people interested so Martine Polanco
Martin Polanco and Dan angle and James
Fadiman if you want to look those up
when I can dig too deep there right now
but I've tried in the last three years
to really pay more attention to and
sensitize myself to these tiny
perturbations several words be sure and
my my visual response to things and to
really hone what I had trained myself to
ignore for so long and Andy you were
talking last night and also today about
being detached from your physical body
after the the hospital experience and so
on and only reintegrating those sensory
inputs and really relishing them and
paying attention to them right recently
and for me I've been doing the same
thing in the last few years instead of
powering ahead and ignoring all these
physical cues and what you might call
intuition which has gotten a bum rap for
very understandable reasons I think it's
very abused and misapplied in a lot of
places but I've been paying attention
trying to pay more attention to this
what we might call primitive but
certainly evolved yes instinctual
reflexive response to things absolutely
and you know the thing is that
actually I'll share a fascinating
experience
I was at a chess tournament 20 years ago
and I'm I'm a rated master very very
strong and I was playing another rated
mastered a big tournament the world
opened in Philadelphia this is like 20
years ago and and I had had a strong
opening advantage against this opponent
and if you're unfamiliar with the game
of chess it would be imagine a wrestling
match where where you haven't pinned the
opponent yet but you've he's having a
hard time moving and and and if it goes
on much longer you are going to pin him
so my opponent was squirming and because
I had the opening advantage and then I
blundered I lost a piece actually I lost
what's known as the exchange a rook for
a knight and which is I lost one of my
stronger pieces for one of his weaker
pieces so he had an edge and he was
really happy and I knew I'm going to
lose the game I mean I was really pissed
with myself because I blundered I wasn't
paying attention
and as I'm staring at the board and
again I'm just really pissed with myself
I hear a voice
somebody whispers from behind and says
you can win this position just like that
and I spun around because a chess
tournament you're not allowed to give
him give advice and there was no one
there and I I thought oh well that's odd
I was like sure someone had just
whispered in my ear and you know just to
jump ahead it was my unconscious mind
that was tapping me on on the shoulder
and but it manifested itself as a voice
and really distinct so I I if you can
imagine I'm looking at the chess board
and I don't want the opponent to see
that that I have any hope or anything so
I'm doing my best Woody Allen imitation
you know like aw I'm going to lose this
and but meanwhile I'm studying the board
really closely and I see an incredible
combination like the kind of combination
that magnus carlsen would would have
been pleased with himself if he had seen
and I won the game and I I lost every
game after that in the in the in the
tournament because I wasn't interested
in the games anymore I wanted to hear
the voice that spoke to me and and the
thing is that your unconscious mind and
the muses the gods the universe are all
whispering to you all the time and and
and you need to close out your conscious
mind find ways to shut it down to hear
those voices because they're whispering
all the time
and and and you need to hear hear them
and heat them so like you I have been
actively looking for ways to to hear
those voices because they're there all
the time and I think for myself at least
I prided myself on not being distracted
by some of those things a meaning
emotional insights that were not tapping
me on the shoulder probably punching me
in the shoulder there are many years and
I remember at one point it's probably
2004 2005 I was agonizing over this
contract it was a it was going to be a
long-term business deal and I had a
number of issues the number of issues
with it as well as the parties involved
and I created these huge pro and con
lists and her at one point agonizing
over this for weeks and it was just
consuming my thoughts 24/7 my girlfriend
at the time asked me she goes do you
even trust this guy and I looked at her
and I go not really and she goes the no
to the deal and I was like good advice
right and of course if I had I
immediately knew the answer and I was
trying to override it with some type of
hyper rational logical apparatus yeah
and it would have been self-defeating in
retrospect I absolutely should not have
done the deal and I'm glad that I did
right so so so three things jumped to
mind
so first you had a choice there right
you didn't have to do the deal but
because you wanted to do the deal you
were looking for ways to rationalize
what your unconscious mind was telling
you right your unconscious mind was
saying don't do the deal and in the same
way that so you don't have to take every
deal and that's one of the to jump back
to Warren Buffett that's one of his
advantages is any written extensively
about this that it's like the market is
a pitcher and and every day it's going
to pitch lots of balls to you and you
don't have to swing but you know so we
got any of them that day you just wait
for a fat pitch and then you swing for
it so so one of the one of the dangers
when you really want something whether
it's a relationship or a business deal
your conscious mind will rationalize and
will shut down your unconscious mind
which is screaming at this point
don't do it walk away whenever things
seem a little strange or a little off
that's your unconscious mind telling you
they're really strange and really off
and walk away because you always have a
choice again whether it's a relationship
or a business deal just walk away okay
in a minute I'm going to come back to
the clicking out of repeated episodes of
depression and ask what might have
correlated a correspondence or even if
it's not cause well I'm just curious but
I'm going to give you a taste of things
to come this is a new exercise I'm going
to be hey wait wait where's that where's
them oh there she is I was looking for
Molly she's asleep
oh yeah no Molly's Molly's resting in an
optical pose which is half of her body
on dog bed head on the extremely hard
floor you know for those who don't know
that Molly is if I have ever met
a sweeter better behaved more beautiful
dog in my life I don't recall man and so
I was hoping she would come on over and
just sit in my lap while by the way
she's sixty pounds and that's like an
easy sit in the lap but um she's maybe
she'll grace us a little later with her
with her with her presence with her with
her joy she's she's she's being a good
intra interview dog she's figured out
that this is this is usually a sideline
gig okay but I'm going to pull out a
random question ah ah the daodejing
which is one of Josh's favorite book so
in the spirit of Josh who's in a in
absentia here at the moment she's going
to pick a random question if I don't
like any of these okay more parkour
let's jump let's do it
what are you okay here we go this is
just pulled out of a a selection of
questions what are you most daring about
well oh boy
that bet bet bet I got to think about
that what am i most daring about well
I'll tell you something 2017 is year
about being daring about everything I
don't know there's a most daring I'm
daring about everything I'm daring about
the future do you view yourself as a
risk-taker
you know it's funny let's reframe risk I
would love that yeah which is why I
throw it out there sure of course so
there are two ways to live life and one
is is in the pursuit of gain or to avoid
loss and those are the two options
I think sure there's another I think
it's pretty binary and you know Nature
has has evolved us as a species to be
risk averse to avoid taking chances and
and not to lose and to overreact to
perceived threats right because the
penalty for overreaction to perceive
threats is less than
under-reacting right and to go back to
fisher the great thing about fisher was
he wasn't afraid to lose he wanted to
win and if it meant he was going to lose
a game so be it because he wanted to win
and and he was willing to lose in order
to win and you know I I play a game now
with myself with the world that I can't
lose so there's no risk it goes back to
those three things connecting with
people which I can do and I think I do
pretty well creating fun and delight and
approaching each person with enthusiasm
which again I'm in total control of and
leaning into each moment expecting magic
I'm in control of all three so what's
the risk I mean I have nothing to lose
and and I mean it's a game that yeah
it's a game you can't lose so what's the
risk the simultaneously you made an
astute observation earlier which we
don't necessarily have to get into the
weeds on but I do think it's a good
observation and they came up we were
having Thai food and I mentioned a book
that I enjoyed a great deal but when I
read it about I'm guessing now maybe
seven or eight years ago called more
money than God by I think his name is
Sebastian that way mmm yeah which I
thought was a very intelligent overview
of the origins of the hedge fund and
some of the characters and styles in the
natural world yeah I not well yeah but
you observed that many hedge funds do
not in fact hedge hedge yeah right so so
yes so hedge funds the concept of a
hedge fund was originated got in 1948
however many years ago that is a I'm not
going to
interrupts the flow of the magic of the
moment to try to calculate that that's
okay we'll go 45 52 wait I'm going to do
it right now 52 at 16 it's 68 years ago
oh no 69 because this is 2017 nun so the
notion of hedge funds was invented six
to nine years ago and but yeah most most
funds do not truly hedge and by hedge
that means taking a position say buying
Apple stock or selling gold or whatever
it is and then simultaneously executing
another transaction that'll protect you
if you're wrong about the first so yeah
most hedge funds don't hedge even though
they think they are that they're very
strategies like being long and short but
yeah they're hedge funds in name only
not not in fact let me grab another
question okay gnarrk or another card we
just call this the park or debt this
risk a conversational charcoal right we
have the rapid-fire questions many of
which we hit the last episodes we're not
going to we're not going to beat those
to death but okay I'm gonna so I'm gonna
pick a new one oh come on come on I'm
not quite right at it away this question
I'm not this is ridiculous this is a
presumptive question I didn't blow them
away I didn't I didn't write this why is
it suspicious when your lover starts
talking baby talk that's ludicrous
I actually love crazy let me pick it let
me pick you the form when have you lost
your way oh well I I think I lost my way
years ago I
I only found my way this last year and
again it was it was getting out of
myself and realizing it's all about the
other person you know by way of metaphor
to create an electric circuit you need
to you can't do it alone right and when
you when you're charged with another
person you you you open up a cosmic
circuit
I don't it's very hard to explain but
I've seen it in real time and and you
you create magic and so I'm I'm on the
hunt for it all the time
I'm um and I'm on the hunt for magic so
let's let's talk about that hunt first
for a second or a a potentially related
tangent sure at some point over the last
two days you said let's talk about
stoicism and then you mentioned you
mentioned hedonism yeah and so I'm going
to let you wrong now and you got what
you requested I was hoping for Molly's
right next to me I guess so so stoicism
which is an enlightened philosophy but
at the same time that stoicism almalik
hey you can't see this but I'm getting
I'm getting licks from Molly here sweet
dog
hedonism in modern culture as a you know
the pursuit of pleasure physical
pleasure but in fact it was it was a
profound Greek philosophy that
originated simultaneously roughly 350 BC
with with stoicism and it was the
pursuit of pleasure but for them the
highest pleasure was a spiritual
pleasure an intellectual pleasure and
for me the highest pleasure is is
creating delight for the other person so
so I'm a heat nough stood out creating
the light and magic for others
and so to go back I'm forgetting what
the question is now but was a really
question it was more of a statement that
I wanted you to come at though maybe
your age well you know what's so
pathetically hedonistic stoic well maybe
yes well I admire the Stoics but for me
the Stoics are Stoics are impassive
impassive meaning not feeling and to
greet success and failure with
indifference and and and I disagree I
believe life should be celebrated and
the Stoics for me and again they're
enlightened aralia since Seneca these
are such wise people but but for me
there's something lacking in in stoicism
because it's a to go back to our our
earlier choice it's playing not to lose
as opposed to playing to win and we are
physical creatures on this plane to
delight and I think that's what life is
all about creating delight for others
and in doing so you have delight for
yourself and which is why I joked
onstage and you know Joss agreed you
know I said I'm the world's best gift
giver and I I came here bearing gifts
for you and I'm really really excited
because my pen pal Warren Buffett I'm
I'm I'm creating a gift for him he keeps
encouraging me to write because he sends
the stuff I write he sends it on to his
friends and and so I'm writing a book
but I started right after our podcast a
parable and I'm rushing to finish it
because uh I'm going to see him on the
19th in a couple weeks so I have a week
to finish this bloody thing and give it
to him as a present and I I'm really
excited about the book I guess
like giving away presents and people
don't realize I'm totally selfish
because I'm the one relishing and
enjoying it whatever pleasure they get
nowhere close to what I'm getting out of
it and I think that also whether it's
hedonism or stoicism that those are in
fact large umbrellas under which there
are many different species and
derivative types of Stoicism before or
hedonism facts almost right right yet so
if you look at say stoicism there are
those who would who might talk about the
practice of stoic joy which is joy but a
joy that is not in tandem with a
commensurate emotional overreaction to
negative events but I've always for
instance one of the things that I've
always thought well you know if I'm
saying 80% stoic let's just say for the
sake of thought exercises if I were 80%
stoic what would the other 20% be and
what Seneca did which is actually what
in a way what Charles Darwin did with to
effectively hater proof or critic proof
his writing was to insert his position
of his staunchest opponents yes in a in
a not only plausible but almost
complimentary way absolutely in his own
works of Seneca knowingness as a
incredible order and also just what
woody to Calder retirin or the debater
and so on took he was his letters in his
letters to Luke ileus one of his
students who he knew was a fan of
Epicurus hmm he would hang choice
tidbits of Epicurus of the epicurean
school mm-hmm and insert them into his
own letters the moral letters to Luke
ileus and and the Epicureans in a lot of
ways were viewed as being the opposite
yeah they're so extend their gardens and
they focused on the little pleasures and
I'm simplifying it here but I always
thought well he did such a good job of
it
knows that I would probably be at least
10% of Kurian hmm and then the last 10%
maybe that's maybe that's some type of
some type of sympathetic hedonist
well early on maybe that's the amount of
an oration yeah are there any particular
you you're very widely read human being
are there any particular philosophers
who draw your attention or who you wish
people who pay more attention to or I
realize this is a lot of commas if you
had to prescribe say high school seniors
to become familiar with one or more
philosophers do any any names or even
schools come to mind oh gee could just
be thinkers doesn't have to be
philosophers right well I mean I
mentioned this a similar question at the
92nd Street Y and I I'm going to start
just to buy myself a little time as I as
I searched my memory for philosophers
that I would broadly recommend is Rumi
the poet Rumi and the wonderful thing
about Rumi is a poet and he was also a
philosopher is if you get you in touch
with the magical and the mysterious and
and I think we need to be in touch with
that all of us in everyday life and so I
would say that the I would read Plato
because Plato in the dialogues would
would create an interlocutor he would
start arguing against himself and again
in in philosophical discourse and in
your own reasoning you have to place
yourself in the position of the other
and if there was one theme today and
certainly in my life in 2016 and moving
forward in my life is the importance of
the other and and what is he or she
thinking or what is he or she want as a
to what I want or what I think and by
the way you have to do this in chess you
know you're you're playing against an
opponent who also has plans
in fact plans diametrically opposed to
yours
and so you it's well to take the other
person in mind and what they're planning
we're going to jump back to that
bookmark that I set a while ago the
depressive ongoing depressive period
intermittent episodes and then I'm at a
decade ago or say lifting a listing did
anything correspond to that well there
any things you introduced or remove I
think there was at that point in my life
so this is 20 2007 I I just made an
abrupt decision to to move away from
everything in the past that I had made
many mistakes
gosh I've made so many mistakes in my
life but but I did to REE to go back to
first principles and fundamentals and
and and by the way I turned my back on
on a couple of successful careers and
and decided to embark on on a new one
and and to set myself up as a advisor to
two major hedge funds and so I I think
it was a decision a break from the past
and in it and a conscious one and I
think that was that was the marker not
only on it let's just say you decide
that on a macro level to break from the
past and many things in the past let's
say you do that after dinner one day you
go to bed how is your next day different
are you separating yourself from contact
with certain people are you identifying
when old thought patterns come up and
stopping and trying to replace them what
what is what is the difference between
you know what the difference is we
talked about it when when when we
walking molly earlier so again you're
listening so you the the the the
audience you just you have to imagine
this we're walking molly on the streets
of san francisco and you know in a
wonderful sylvan Canyon and clave that
that i've never known about and we're
anyway a tim resides and so we're
walking molly and molly when we're
walking on the left side of the street
you always want Molly away from the
traffic and so we're walking along and
and on on the left side molly is okay
but when we switch to the other side of
the street Molly has to be on your right
side which is again away from the
traffic and in Molly again this is by
way of metaphor you said that Molly is
is more it's a little more awkward for
her so she's got to be a little more
conscious and and thoughtful about what
she does when we're walking on the right
side of the street and when I made a
conscious break to end I mean it ends at
a relationship and I ended a business
and and decided to start anew and you
become conscious you know I think too
much of our lives are an automatic pilot
and and so like Molly walking on the
right side of the street just it it's
it's a little different for her so she
becomes conscious of everything she does
and I think that's really important to
be to live consciously and mindfully and
one way to do that is to get yourself
out of old ways of being take a new path
to work not saying you should be
dramatic and and and everything is I
didn't start a new but you can you can
make little choices and again to live
mindfully and consciously
[Music]
yeah so that that's it to be the
decision you made and you've played out
some very cool word origins or should
say word components at the very least
now is Nick up mix up etymology and
entomology but I'm at a mall and
entomology we're not you're talking
about if we're eating paleo for instance
what would we will date a new
replacement for companion be if
companion which if you were to look at
this let's just say since I don't speak
Latin Spanish combined with bread with
bread breaking bread with someone else
you know what would the Paleo course
would that be or matrix the fact that if
you look at matriarch or matrimony there
there's a mother component mother
related the the decision you made and I
might be making this up but I don't
think I'm making it out in signal a
decision to cut away yes a cutting away
to decide is to cut to cut away incision
correct so the cutting away of
relationship business all these things
if well I shouldn't I shouldn't project
but for myself to do something like that
it's very often something I know I need
to do it's something that on many levels
I want to do but I put it off for a very
very long time I get close and then I
assure then I flinch and then I go back
to my easier automatic way of doing
things or the devil that I know the
comforts that I'm afraid to replace
because of the unknown what led you to
get to the point
those are certain conversation certain
journaling exercises they're what led
you to finally make the breaker and make
the break I I think you just realized
that for me I mean it's different for
each person you just whether you're
being authentic and and I realized I
wasn't being authentic and I had to make
a break and and and and start a new life
and and and so I think authenticity is a
big thing
it's hard to be authentic and and but
it's and their challenges and and I was
going to say risks but I again to go
back I don't know that there are risks
if you play a game and the game is all
about creating fun and delight for
everyone around you and you know this
reminds me of a joke ha so I don't know
if you've heard this one so guy walks
into a bar and by the way this is a
profound philosophical point that I'll
make but it will only become clear once
I I tell you the joke
so the guy walks into a bar and and it
goes up to the bartender and orders a
drink and the bartender looks and goes I
haven't seen you in the bar before and
the bar the customer says well no I'm I
just came to town and the bartender goes
oh well what brings down in and what do
you do and he says I'm a gambler and the
bartender says really and and and he
says yeah I I'm a gambler a professional
gamblers what I do for a living and the
bartender goes really you can make a
living at that he says yeah I never lose
and the park tend to go so give me a
break and that the gambler guy or the
customer says that yeah no I've never I
don't lose and so the bartender goes
okay
give me an example a day I make me a bet
and so the customer says to the
bartender look I'm warning you I'm a I'm
a professional gambler I just warned you
that I never lose are you sure you want
to do this and the Bartram goes
absolutely and he says okay I'll bet you
$50 I'm going to make sure I get this
bit right I'll bet you $50 that I can
bite my left eye and bartender rolls his
eyes and slams down 50 bucks and and
goes you're on
you're on and so the the Mogambo guy
takes out his left eye and bites it in
his mouth and and and pops it back in
and the bartender is furious but the
gambler guy says I warned you and scoops
up the money and and and then the UH
have you heard this one okay so again
the path is really funny and then I'll
make the philosophical point about life
and so the bartender goes okay give me
another chance and and gambol guy says
look I'm a professional I just warned
you I just took $50 are you sure you
want to do this and the barking goes
yeah give me another chance and the and
the gamble guy says okay I'll bet you
another $50 that I can bite my other eye
and the bartender goes wait a second
okay I missed the fact that that one I
was glass but there's no way that you're
blind I know you don't have to glass
eyes okay you're on
and it brought down 50 bucks and by the
way other patrons are now circling
around watching what's going on and
egging the bartender on and so the
gamble guy takes out his dentures and
and gently bites his eye his other eye
with the with his dentures and that the
bartender is steaming now because he's
lost two bats it's furious and the gamma
guy says I wonder and anyway the
gambling guy throughout the evening is
getting drunk he's buying drinks for
everybody he goes to the back of the bar
and then he comes back to the bartender
and says look I'm gonna make it up to
you I make another bet and now the whole
part of the whole bar is around him and
and so he says I'll bet you 500 dollars
that I can stand on this bar right here
on the bar stand up on one leg and you
see that vodka bottle behind you I can
pee into that bottle and not a drop of
people go anywhere else but that bottle
and the part in the glass there is no
way the
that's going to happen and he puts down
500 bucks and so the Gambhir guy so the
gambler guy and by the way he's pretty
drunk at this point he can barely stand
up he gets up at the top of the bar
pulls it out and pees everywhere but the
vodka bottle pees all over the bartender
and the bartender's laughing his head
off and so was everyone else right and
and the the guy the gamble guy gets you
know it does his finish his business and
gets down off the bar and and then the
bartender triumphantly grabs the the 500
bucks from the gambler guy and he says
ha I thought you never lose and the Gama
guy says I didn't he's what do you mean
I just took $500 from you and he said
the game against is yeah but you see
that table those guys back there those
college guys I bet them $2,000 that I
could stand up on this bar and pee all
over you and not only would you not
object you'd be laughing when I did it
and and so so so the interesting thing
there talk about the hedged bet right
the as we would talk about hedge funds
earlier is that the payoff is uh there's
a usurer payoff he lost the 500 but
there was a much bigger payoff and in
life
if your focus is on the other person and
delighting the other person again
whether it's a job interview or a
relationship a date or you're looking to
get funding for your reer startup or pee
all over and give 1100 and right step
but the payout the universe pays you
back on the back end and and and that's
a face so that's that's the gospel that
I preach is the gospel of the other and
and focus on the other and exclusively
and you'll get tremendous delight
yourself and and and the universe has a
way of throwing you an extra at
so much more than you could think and
I'll give you an example of magic and I
said before the the the thing I if I
said this is a nice secretary I did I
talked about getting a present for
Warren Buffett and then and then the the
gallery okay so so I I create a
Christmas present for him Buffett I want
to send it to him right and my penpal
and and so I created a framed pack of
Beeman's gum which used to sell as a
child and so it took me the Beeman's gum
for those of you don't know the company
that made Beeman's gum went out of
business about a decade ago and and
warren buffett when he was a child used
to sell it and and I tracked down on the
Internet
a candy collector and and asked him if
he had a pack of Beeman's gum from like
50 years ago like like an old ancient
pack and he said I might in my warehouse
in Montana and sure enough he found it
and I said I pay any price for it I
bought it and then I had a clicker for
right from small beginnings anyway I had
a framed pack of gum so I was going to
send a Warren Buffett for Christmas so
this is December 20 20th or so and I
meant I'm in a gallery in Tribeca and
the gallery owners New York City New
York City yes I'm sorry
and the gallery owner says do you like
the frame it had just been frames and I
said oh this is so beautiful he's just
gonna love this not she doesn't know who
I am and doesn't know who this is going
to it doesn't say for anybody and um and
I said oh how am I going to get this to
Nebraska and she said what do you mean I
said well if I send it FedEx
I don't care how many times I bubble
wrap it the gum will fall off the frame
like it'll fall off the backings shadow
box right shadow box right and I thought
oh it's gonna it has to be courier and I
said how am I gonna get it there and she
said I'll take care of that
I said oh great you know a delivery
service and she said that will deliver
personally she said yeah I'll take care
of it I said well what delivery service
because I'd like to know just for future
reference she said oh I'm sorry I don't
think I'll deliver this personally I
said what I squinted at her I said what
she said yeah I'll take care of this
free charge I said excuse me this is
Nebraska right it's not like going to
some fun location like with respect to
those of you rascai worried all cuz I
hate mail um where's the wither it's the
winner it's the winter right there right
fit right right why would you want to be
going to Nebraska and um she said she
looked at me and she said I'll do it for
free uh I can see how important this is
to you and I I was so stunned and I just
looked at her young woman maybe 28 29
and I said um I said you know I can't
let you do that that's the best gift
anyone's ever given me and I'm the
world's best gift giver and here I was I
got like like you know one up I got one
up and I said I said oh my gosh
really that's the kind of thing I would
have said and I said I can't let you do
that
I I'll pay for you to do it I'm not
going to ruin the magic because there
was some impulse in you that wanted to
do that to offer that to me and I'm
gonna have to I'll I'll pay for the trip
so thank you and and that's an example
of the magic she didn't know who it was
going to I didn't know who I was she
just knew it was important to me and in
the end the because I was so focused on
getting this present to someone that I
cared about and she could see that she
was swept into the magic and that's an
example of the magic that happens when
you just focused on someone else instead
of yourself and uh boy I was humbled by
that I mean wow
I'm really went up in the in the present
giving department
[Music]
so the magic is focusing on the other on
the other yeah yeah well I think you're
a master of tonight I didn't know the
pre the fad we met what did we do we
first meet unless refers to thousand 14
15 14 I thank Riley 14 yeah to giant I
didn't know the atom free 2014 but you
strike me as an expert in what another
podcast guess Gabrielle Reece Gabby
Reece sure going first
she said go first I asked her if she had
any parting requests for the audience
she should go first
meaning smile first make eye contact
first say hi first you're very good at
that I think that's part of eliciting a
potential magic of that situation
absolutely when you're really the secret
to everything to creating in the world
whether it's creating a relationship or
creating a business I don't care what it
is is you have a vision of what's
possible and you convey that vision to a
potential partner whether it's a
business or a romantic partner of what's
possible and and you get them excited
about it and you get other people
excited about it if it's a business and
so on and and so yeah it's about having
visions positive visions of what's
possible you know and this is 2017 and
I'm I think the world is in a very
perilous place right now but I'm very
excited for the world because because
this is a fulcrum moment and by fulcrum
moment I mean a moment when you can
achieve great results maximally
leveraging whatever resources you've got
like now is the time to act and we get
fulcrum moments in our lives
um as individuals and as countries and
as a planet and this is a fulcrum ear
and we all sense it that great changes
positive or negative we got to be
careful and and and to seize the fulcrum
moment now is the time to press hard and
I think the world's got to do that with
with positive visions and excite and
it's all about the other excite everyone
with a positive vision and we can create
magic in the world or not and then we're
in trouble I'm really excited about 2017
for myself and for the world yeah before
we wrap up I think we might we might
have a date with a Russian bath in our
future but before we close up the
conversation give any parting requests
for the audience questions for the
audience suggestions for the audience
anything you'd like them to take with
them well that was a big one that this
is a fulcrum year I'm telling you just
intuitively I know for myself and I'm
sure as as you the listener reflect on
your life and and there are great
opportunities the world is such
tremendous beauty and possibility it's
so exciting right now and and yet
everyone's focused on the negative and
instead focus on the other and and
positive and creating magic lean into
each moment in each encounter creating
magic and and by the way that's a great
editing principle like when you're
you're in an argue you're about to argue
with the cab driver or or or with your
spouse or with your best friend or
whatever ask yourself is what you're
going to say create the light and the
other person or magic and if not don't
say it and well actually do that last
night with
am with the hostess at a restaurant when
the restaurant was fully booked up
raining outside we walk in and and in
fact it wasn't we it was just the two of
us walked in because we had we had
another party with us waiting in nuber
because we didn't think it would be
possible potentially to get a table
right and I don't remember the exact
wording that you use but you walked up
and to Bryn I remember in like a hurry
yeah and uh and you just walked into the
exchange opening first second expecting
us to get a table right and lo and
behold she said I feel like your chances
are very good after in a 30 seconds of
Adam turning on the charm and then
called call their whole party in and a
few short minutes later after some
little bit of me drinking wine and all
of us drinking sparkling water we got
arguably the best table in the house it
was the best table and wasn't us table
knows yeah and because I just couldn't
really I I start my Brit was just about
creating some fun for her and she
realized we were fun people and fun
energy and damn straight she was going
to give us a table she um
Shazam yeah out of it I I always loved
our conversations and many more ahead on
our show conversational parkour exactly
right hub parkour which is my favorite
kind of parkour because I can't damage
my knees and is there anywhere you would
like people to learn more about you
online or elsewhere website anything
else that you'd like to mention well
they can always get in touch with me
through my website
Robinson global strategies there's a
contact one there and they want to talk
about global strategy or or magic they
can always drop me a line and and and
I'll respond
alright well on that note I think this
is a great place to to temporarily table
this ongoing conversation that we have
and
everybody listening anything we
mentioned if it is linkable on the
internet you can find all of the
resources and whatnot at the show notes
with every other episode and those can
be found at 4-hour workweek com4 slash
podcast all spelled out for our work
week comm for such podcast and until
next time thank you for listening
hey guys this is Tim again just a few
more things before you take off number
one this is five bullet Friday do you
want to get a short email from me and
would you enjoy getting a short email
for me every Friday is that provides a
little morsel of fun before the weekend
and five both writing is a very short
email where I share the coolest things
I've found or that I've been pondering
over the week that could include
favorite new albums that I've discovered
it could include gizmos and gadgets and
all sorts of weird [ __ ] that I've
somehow dug up in the the world of the
esoteric as I do
it could include favorite articles that
I have read and that I've shared with my
close friends for instance and it's very
short it's just a little tiny bite of
goodness before you head off for the
weekend so if you want to receive that
check it out just go to 4-hour workweek
dot-com that's 4-hour workweek com all
spelled out and just drop in your email
and you will get the very next one and
if you sign up I hope you enjoyed this
episode is brought to you by 99designs
I've used 99designs for years for all
sorts of graphic design needs whether
you need a logo website cover anything
else 99designs was created to make great
designs accessible to everyone to make
the process of getting designs much much
easier so when I first started out
for instance testing prototype covers
and getting prototypes commissioned for
our body
I want the contest route that is one
option this is a great solution feeling
for fast affordable design work and the
ability to choose from dozens of options
risk-free let's say you need something
late night quick turnaround well people
in other times other countries can also
help you solve that problem since then
I've worked with 99 designs on a
separate path or a different option
and that is the one-to-one project
service so in a number of cases and I'll
give you one example when I wanted to
create the cover for my audiobook that's
how of Seneca this is a very important
project to me I decided to use their
one-to-one project service and with this
service you can invite a specific
designers your project agree in a price
and then work together until you're
satisfied now I need iterate my feedback
and all this stuff and I haven't shared
it yet but we also got some incredibly
good really some of the best
illustrations I've ever seen from using
this one-to-one project service with a
handful of different designers and
illustrators it blew my mind 99 designs
makes this all very easy and efficient
so you can check out the Tao of Seneca
design and other work that I and your
fellow listeners for that matter have
done on 99 designs at 99 designs comm
forward slash Tim again that's 99
designs dot-com forward slash Tim this
episode is brought to you by wealthfront
wealthfront is the future of financial
advice they've become incredibly popular
among my friends in Silicon Valley and
across the country because they provide
the same high end financial advice that
the best private wealth managers to
overton ultra wealthy but for any
account size and at a fraction of the
cost
for instance they monitor your portfolio
every day across more than a dozen asset
classes to look for opportunities to
rebalance or harvest tax losses now
would you do the same are you doing the
same probably not and the powers on the
software wealth front now manages more
than four billion dollars in assets
which is up from around 2.5 billion when
they started advertising on this podcast
they're growing incredibly quickly
unlike old-fashioned Private Wealth
matters wealth front is powered by
innovative technology making it the most
tax efficient low-cost hassle-free way
to invest they don't have loads of sales
teams or retail locations so they can
deliver all of this sophisticated
financial advice and these services at a
fraction of the cost of a traditional
financial advisor so the very least go
to wealth from calm forward slash tim
and take their free risk assessment
survey it only takes a couple of minutes
and wealthfront will recommend a
personalized portfolio of investments in
other words they'll tell you exactly
where they would put your money
so even if you don't use their service
you have a huge leg up and you have
additional information for making good
decisions they use investment theory to
automate good financial behavior and
decisions that people typically don't
make but should so go to well front comm
forward slash Tim to get your first 15k
managed for free or just to get more
details check it out well front comm
forward slash hip
[Applause]